these two young Uganda's have developed
an app that can reveal breast cancer at
an early stage but this research
institute is still closed because of a
strike so Morse a tween a and David Meza
gwa will have to do their work in the
cafeteria instead the app comes in the
unusual form of a glove with sensors
that are linked to a cell phone Morris
explains what inspired the app I musta
lost a relative breast cancer and died
that's how it came up with the idea so
with vistas in Uganda particular Africa
this is different meaning that growth a
good read is high but the survival rate
is kinda done early detection is crucial
when it comes to saving lives the
biggest problem in rural areas where
there are no oncologist is that breast
cancer is detected too late the first
point of contact for many patients is
rural doctors so it's their feedback the
young inventors are keen to hear they
want to know if the images of
irregularities in the breast captured by
the gloves sensors are accurate and
would a doctor pay 350 euros for this
app that would send the images to
specialists in the capital Kampala I
think it is going to be very very very
important if it is brought on market
small centers like this we cannot afford
a monograph we cannot afford ultrasound
but we can afford this breast cancer
appears to be on the rise in this area
and no one knows why some think it could
be related to changes in women's diets
these activists want to raise awareness
about the importance of early breast
cancer detection but fear of being
stigmatized in their villages leads many
women to ignore the first signs of the
disease they don't want to be associated
with you or your family they don't want
to they may not want to marry in your
family you know
and there are many chances the husband's
live there they are whites and also the
employers may not continue to employ you
health care is one of Uganda's biggest
challenges and one of its biggest
markets some of Morris and David's
friends are working on a different app
one that enables early detection of
malaria and tuberculosis there are very
very many technology kids kids who are
interested in technology kids do a lot
of different stuff but this limited
technology and and the resources are
really limited I look abroad and I see
that the world is ahead of us and
they're like maybe out of 10 you at step
one and someone is already a step nine
about Tristan every second Ugandan is
under 15 and the tech scene is thriving
with more support young people could
help unlock the country's potential
you